well good morning that's probably the
high point I remember my my son after it
come out of school our older son God
accepted medical school and he got the
call on a Friday afternoon and they were
to start on Monday and we took him out
to dinner that night and I said Kevin
understand this is probably the high
point of the next 10 years of your life
and I could tell you for sure he would
agree that that was true because it was
it was tough stuff this is an
unbelievable place to be doing what
we're about to do there's and I've
talked about this many times over the
last I don't know years but most
intensely over the last few months as
well too I've used a term different
times that that that word a transition
point in corporate governance and as
I've thought about that it's not correct
we're in an inflection point things are
changing and changing dramatically and
they're going to and what better place
to be then at Columbia University why
well what it brings from a history and a
knowledge absolutely but probably more
important is balance in thought and
guidance where people try to understand
an environment look at that environment
study that environment listen to foot
the constituents that are in that
environment that go from from investors
analyst proxy and vipers advisors
shareholders customers employees try to
deal with global economic changes
geopolitical changes quarterly earnings
and is declared sometimes in the press
seasons earning and starting next week
and shareholders that may ask for and or
demand buybacks or dividend increases
and in all that today we've got aboard
setting at the center of that and the
questions are being asked and rightfully
so what's their role and how are they
performing that role what should it be
how should it be defined how should it
change if it should change how could
they do it better what what part do
activist play in it what part do active
investors playing that you'll hear from
the lab at the end to the at the end of
the day and he would call himself an
active investor not an activist but we
could point to examples where activists
have created an enormous beneficial
change in an organization we could also
point to examples of where that has
created horrible outcomes and so how do
we deal with that and what should happen
how should we view it what role can you
individually play in it each of you in a
very different role at the current time
but it will have a voice in that and I
think the challenge is how do we have a
voice that takes us to a new place in a
thoughtful way in a balanced way that
gives some guidance to what maybe should
be the transition we've lived for
decades with boards owning corporate
governance but now with things like
proxy access maybe we're moving into a
near era of shared governments and if so
how do you do that what are the
guidelines you follow and I think the
thing that we need to think about as we
move into this is that this change can
come from within we can do it to
ourselves or somebody will do it to us
and generally speaking change is better
done if folks like you and others here
at Columbia University have an input
into that willing to open up and change
in new ways things that were
uncomfortable last year maybe need to be
very comfortable next year and I think
one of the great things we have gone for
us here this is named the milstein
Center for Corporate Governance IRA has
been at this for four or five decades
giving guidance on corporate governance
in very different environments than it
is today with the major corporations in
this country and around the world and
the amazing part about where we are is
that this man is open up the aperture
wider now and looking at it in a new way
and saying these are time for change do
we need to activist boards not just
activists and if we did what would be
the result of that so we don't know for
sure exactly where the end point is we
know what the goal is and that is to
help define and build a road map for the
change that needs to occur to
incorporate all the constituents in that
discussion and come to a better place
than we are today and so I think the
challenge then is how do we get on
offense not unda fence not be reacting
to what's going on and to be moving with
the current but rather think our way
through it have discussions have debates
and that's what we're here for today
you're going to be seen folks that all
have positions you will be seeing folks
that have different positions and we're
going to encourage you and do encourage
you doing in put yourself into that and
ask questions of those folks and become
a part of that dialogue and become a
part of the future and how we change
things and what we want to do and how we
want to do it so thank you for being
here thank you for taking the time to be
with us nope you find that this day will
be as energetic as we go through it as
as we hope we planned it to be Marcel
you won't come back up